en cuir noir c'est l'essentiel de ce
panier garni aidera probablement une
famille dans le besoin
une chaîne de l'espoir organisées par
les bénévoles du mcdo solidaire situé à
saint barthélémy dans les quartiers nord
de marseille
c'est lors du premier confinement que
ces textes établissement de restauration
rapide a été réquisitionnée en urgence
plus de 3500 colis alimentaires y
étaient distribués chaque semaine on va
essayer de s'auto-organiser pendant le
premier confinement et on a réussi à
créer une machine de guerre qui a été
mis en place par la solidarité et
l'intelligence collective
au lieu de sortir des hamburgers on sort
d huile rire les pattes
tout ce que ces personnels en ont besoin
alarmés par la situation des bénévoles
de tout milieu social viennent prêter
main forte à l'occasion de ce deuxième
confinement aujourd'hui c'est pauline
étudiante qui est venu apporter son
soutien ça me tient à coeur champ à une
césure donc forcément j'ai envie de
travailler
je suis venu plusieurs fois une fois
c'était que des femmes ont parfois des
papas qui ne récupérez des couches lait
pour les bébés et on voit que c'est très
très compliqué pour eux de venir déjà
ici parce que c'est quelque part c'est
honteux pour eux alors que l'on bat en
vrai nom une misère honteuse pour
certains assumée par d'autres mari
retraité a longtemps aider les plus
nécessiteux
aujourd'hui c'est à son tour d'accepter
cette main tendue
quand je travaillais j'ai fait beaucoup
de bénévolat au secours populaire
et malheureusement c'est moi maintenant
que je me retrouve mais j'ai pas honte r
ma situation c'est que je suis dans le
besoin j'ai une petite retraite
heureusement la paix à des assauts
sociaux comme ici la population à aider
et diverses des retraités des étudiants
mais aussi des personnes en situation
irrégulière qui vivent habituellement de
travail informel des activités qui
malheureusement sont à l'arrêt depuis le
premier confinement sont mariés comme je
travaille pas on a besoin de faire la
course
avant le travail de noir comme il n'a
pas le papier est maintenant combien le
corona il travaille que quand je lis le
journal
je vois que tout le monde est en
difficulté et moi alors qu'il ne possède
absolument rien c'est donc normal que je
sois très inquiète
une demande en constante augmentation
dans ce lieu emblématique qui avait été
l'épicentre d'un long conflit social
jusqu'à sa liquidation judiciaire le 12
décembre 2019
aujourd'hui kamel l'un des syndicalistes
phare à l'initiative de la plateforme
souhaite transformer le restaurant
solidaire en sic une société coopérative
d'intérêt collectif pour créer de
l'emploi et accroître l'aide alimentaire
le meilleur moyen pour combattre la
délinquance la prostitution et le
radicalisme c'est que par le travail et
aujourd'hui si nous l'avons des voyous
low cost dans nos quartiers et la
prostitution et ces jeunes qui sont en
perdition
c'est parce qu'on leur tend pas la main
pour le moment la structure se développe
n'étant pas reconnue par la préfecture
elle et bénéficient donc d'aucune aide
de la part de la banque alimentaire mais
uniquement de dons d'associations ou de
commerces locaux
un soutien qui n'est pas de trop alors
que la pandémie se poursuit et que
l'hiver n'a pas encore débuté